like it because if I PK a low level, I get
a lot of karma points, but it's the same for the people above me, so if we complain that we've been made the perpetrators, Mr.
Pencilgon
won't kill us, you wild player
killer.  It's my fault that I'm going to do this against a low-level opponent,
but I
can fight against the extension of Monster Shooting Club SF2 who has no interest in me, so I have to thank Sada-kun.
Don't make it a
big deal. Don't just think about it. The
four information players are just losing in terms of level, equipment, and
status.
[Music] [
Music]
Get it [
[Music] As expected, it's
just for taking pictures of monsters.  He
's a magician who has mastered deba. His status is higher than his. Why did
all of his curses get bounced back? I was
attacked by a magician's PK killer before, so I
know that magic is quite troublesome, so I
keep it just in case.  It would have been
dangerous if the silver had not actually had all the counters for the king's curse.
At least watch me die from my own poison. [
Music] I'll
give it to you.
[Music]
If you're aiming for it.  He's the guy who looks like he's going to make fun of me. The only
problem that can be avoided even without skills is
how to deal damage to high-level players who are wearing heavy armor, given the attack speed I've experienced.
[Music]  It's
true.